born I want to spend the rest of my life
Ben Higgins melted hearts with that
proposal on Mondays bachelor finale now
he and fiance Lauren Bushnell are
dishing on her huge ring and telling ET
what's next I heard this is the most
expensive ring in bachelor history
you know I would love to say I knew how
much it was worthy I don't I just got
the ad was also the one that I felt most
comfortable with like holding in my hand
you know I was like this has to be how
many carats
yes George Salle VT the Neo Layne Art
Deco ring is actually worth close to a
hundred thousand dollars but is a lavish
televised wedding next I think it's
something we both are open to I mean
that's another day we just want to get
married and have a wedding with our
family and friends there and celebrates
we've cut the costs on a wedding yeah
right now I'm going back to work and
focusing on are there any plans and that
was something we talked about early on
when we met and I don't know how soon
that's gonna take place because we also
want to enjoy life together
but not you know it's nothing we're
scared of and despite speculation
neither Ben nor Lauren will be in the
Dancing with the Stars ballroom of this
season Warren and I being together is my
main concern and I don't think adding
too much more to that right now is there
anything though they aren't out of
Hollywood completely is specially with
their new famous friend and avid
bachelor fan
kaley cuoco Haley just had reached out
with like her her encouragement at one
point so she's a huge fan and I think
it's really awesome to see people like
Haley who have been so accomplished in
and Hollywood they go watching The
Bachelor really cheering on you know our
relationship
my whole life